why
so during our discussion of civil war
issue number one we had talked about the
events that really kind of led into the
civil war itself that is to say we saw
the new warriors confronting a group of
super villains
we saw one of the super villains nitros
self-destructing and destroying a large
portion of Stanford Connecticut which in
turn started a chain reaction which
ultimately led to superheroes kind of
drawing this line in the sand where we
had Captain America going underground
and Ironman taking the side of the
federal government but what we see
between the issues number one and number
two of the civil war is kind of a
beefing up so to speak of the storyline
we really kind of see a lot of the gaps
being filled in with regards to various
superheroes getting involved and
different aspects of the events as
they're unfolding in addition to seeing
some super villains kind of being
incorporated into the fold of both
shield and the anti superhuman
Registration movement and ultimately as
we progress throughout the Civil War
storyline we will see that these tie-ins
will become more and more expansive in
addition to being larger in number and
so what we're going to do over the
course of this video is we're going to
discuss these tie-ins in addition to
really kind of following up with a
second part of our Civil War discussion
so starting with she-hulk issue number
eight we see several things going on
here one of the first things we see is
really just kind of a way for Marvel to
segue into events that will take place
later on why establishing to us that she
Hulk and John Jameson are in a very
serious relationship in addition what we
also see is that rage and justice to
Avengers and former members of the New
Warriors have enlisted the aid of
she-hulk due to the fact that some
anonymous individual has created a
website called destroy all warriors calm
and as a result of this they have listed
the identities of everyone who was a
member of the new Warriors and people
are out killing them in addition to
killing members of their families or
else just beating them in a severe state
what we also see is that once she
files a lawsuit against the company that
is hosting this website escape
enterprises her identity is revealed by
the person who is hosting this website
now we switch over to John Jameson and
what we see is that John Jameson is
meeting with Steve Rogers and Steve
Rogers has enlisted his aide to tell him
whether or not she Hulk is willing to
fight on his side now John Jameson
doesn't really know whether or not she
Hulk will fight for Steve Rogers any in
fact tells him that there really he
really doesn't know whether that's the
case or not and he's not really
comfortable divulging any information
that Jennifer Walters wouldn't want him
to divulge at this point we jump back to
the court scene and what we see is that
Tony Stark actually reveals to she-hulk
that east cape Enterprises is a dummy
corporation and that he actually has the
name and address of the person who was
running the website which he gives to
she-hulk with no real strings attached
what we also see is that she-hulk in
addition to former members of the new
warriors confront this individual and
this individual turns out to be Carlton
Laphroaig I think is his name and he is
actually a former new warrior himself
the only difference here is that he
actually didn't have any powers he was
really kind of a mascot so think of him
as the Robin of the new Warriors he was
pivotal in terms of being a cheerleader
more or less but he didn't really have
any abilities per se what we also see is
that his rationale for creating this
website was that he was hoping it would
be a way to kind of force former members
of the new Warriors to kind of give up
in order to prevent future repercussions
as a result of their identities being
revealed and that he didn't actually
mean for any of this violence and anyone
to actually die in the process what we
ultimately see as we kind of progress
towards the end of this issue is that
the neighborhood becomes aware that the
new Warriors are confronting Carlton
Laphroaig and they actually kind of turn
into an angry mob of sorts and begin to
kind of incite violence but we see that
John Jameson arrives in time to save
she-hulk in addition to the other
members of the new Warriors and then
proposes to she-hulk
so while I wouldn't go as far as to say
that the events and she-hulk issue
number eight are boring or anything what
I would say is that I don't believe that
story is nearly as rich and entertaining
as the story that we get in Wolverine
vol three issue number 42 and the reason
why is because one of the greatest
aspects of Wolverine comics is the inner
monologue that we get to follow along
with as we progress through the comic
book and this issue is no different now
at this particular point in time one
thing to bear in mind is that Wolverine
is both the member of the New Avengers
as well as an x-man so he really kind of
holds allegiances to both sides and as
we begin the comic we see that he is
involved in an effort to stop the
actions of the crusader a religious
fundamentalist who is hijacked a c-130
and plans to use stolen money to finance
a terrorist plot that will destroy
several headquarters of superheroes we
see that Wolverine is able to dispatch
the Crusader along with his minions
pretty swiftly and actually crashes the
plane in a cornfield from there he
travels to a bar where he sees the
Stanford incident unfold on television
and he's actually paged by the Avengers
to assist in the cleanup process while
he's assisting in cleanup we see him
overhearing a conversation between Tony
Stark and Captain America where we
learned that nitro actually survived his
self detonation and that he hitched a
ride out of town on a truck from there
we learned that several days have passed
with no real information regarding the
whereabouts of nitro and we actually see
that Wolverine is asked to leave a
restaurant due to the fact that the
patrons who are humans are really kind
of fearful and don't want him there
because of the current climate involving
superheroes and this I think is one of
the coolest aspect of the story because
it really kind of gives us a very
nuanced idea and really kind of a
beefing up of how it is that the world
exists at this point in time with
regards to humanity's perception of
superheroes as he leaves the restaurant
he takes the back door and he is
confronted by a group of staff from the
restaurant who have knives and various
weapons but of course they flee once he
reveals his claws
from this point we jump to the meeting
that we discuss in civil war volume one
I'm sorry the the first video that we
did in civil war where we see that
various individuals are discussing and
they're talking about the superhuman
Registration and so on and so forth we
see that Wolverine meets with Tony Stark
who tells him not to go searching for
nitro but we really kind of see Tony
Stark rewarding this in a way that he's
really kind of asking for Wolverine to
go search for him just because of the
fact that the search for nitro was in
the hands of shield and he says that if
shield knew where he was or knew how to
find him they would have found him
already which really kind of leaves it
out there that nitro just may very well
not be found at this point Wolverines
unable to accept this he is unwilling to
accept this just because of the fact
that the actions of nitro led to the
deaths of several hundred children which
he is will unwilling to let go
unpunished so we really see him kind of
talk to Luke Cage and when he's talking
to Luke Cage Luke Cage is of course
siding with registration and Wolverine
makes the statement that this whole anti
register or this whole registration
movement with regards to superheroes is
very similar to the Nazi Germany
movement and of course Luke Cage is
really unable to kind of compare the two
and and says that our government and the
actions of their superhuman registration
policies is vastly different from what's
going on in Germany but Wolverine
doesn't really buy it we see that
Wolverine travels to the Xavier mansion
and attempts to enlist the aid of Emma
Frost and Cyclops
in order to track nitro but of course
they turn it down and the reason why is
because at this point in time they don't
want to get involved in the civil war
just because there's already enough
hatred out there for mutants already
they don't simply want to compound that
by coming out in support of I'm sorry
coming out against a bill that humans
support which will ultimately turn them
against them more than they already have
we actually see that wolverine
eventually leaves and travels back to
Stanford Connecticut where he picks up
the scent of nitro and the truck that he
had hitched a ride on and then the comic
really kind of comes to a close as we
begin to realize that he is going to go
on this quest for vengeance
despite the fact that Tony Stark had
asked him not to
so we're civil war issue number one
really kind of set the stage really kind
of introduced to us this idea that
things were changing that things were
progressing and that superhuman
Registration was on its way to becoming
a reality
Civil War issue number two really kind
of builds on that and in this comic we
will see that a superhuman Registration
actually becomes a reality and what we
see is that as we begin to open the
comic as we begin to progress to the
first few pages that shield has captured
several super villains now the concern
that shield has specifically Maria Hill
is that around 72 supervillains have
been captured in an extremely short
amount of time and she believes is
virtually impossible that Captain
America could have done that in such a
short amount of time and so her concern
is that Captain America is no longer
working alone that Captain America has
allies but they don't really know who
those allies are from here we really
kind of jumped to a fast-paced sort of
thing going on in the sense that we see
the superhuman Registration has now
passed Congress and that in 24 hours it
will become law and that individuals who
do not register themselves who do not
reveal their identities to the federal
government will be branded as outlaws
and will be rounded up accordingly in
addition we see the Tony Stark is hailed
as a hero by the federal government and
that Captain America is considered
public enemy number one for the most
part we also switch to the Fantastic
Four now not a whole lot is given to us
here but this is extremely important as
we progressed later on in the comics
because what we see here is that Reed
Richards is working on some kind of a
top-secret project that he is keeping
confidential from everyone including his
family in addition I'd also like you
guys to take particular note of the
thing who was kind of taking care of the
children of Susan storm and Reed
Richards Franklin Richards and so on and
this really kind of hits home with the
idea of what's going on with the Civil
War that everybody is stretched then
that it affects everybody and that
subtle things like being able to have
dinner with the family
just isn't there now from this point we
actually see a pretty interesting thing
with Tony Stark what we see here is that
he actually expresses doubt over
they're not what they're doing is right
he doesn't have this absolute certainty
that things are going to work out well
he is really just kind of hoping that
they're doing the right thing now this I
think is kind of important because it
gives us depth to Tony Stark it gives us
this understanding that he does not
believe that what's happening may be
absolutely right and then it may go
totally awry he does not have 100% faith
in this cause and he genuinely believes
that what he's doing is going to set
them along the path to regaining public
trust in addition to providing a more
responsible atmosphere for superheroes
now from here we jump to 24 hours later
and this is past the deadline this is
once the midnight hour has gone by and
those who have not registered themselves
are now considered outlaws and what we
see is that a superhero who is
bulletproof named the Patriot he's
really stopped a mugging but now he's
being chased by shield and what we see
is that the Patriot along with the Young
Avengers are caught by shield and they
are rounded up to be taken to a holding
center because of the fact that they
choose they chose not to register now we
switch to daredevil and we don't really
know where daredevil is but we see that
he's having a conversation with another
individual and that he reveals that
Captain America is undercover in an
attempt to free the patriot along with
the Young Avengers from this point we
switch to the vehicle that is
transporting the Patriot and the Young
Avengers and we see that it's actually
Captain America driving the vehicle he
throws the passenger out who was a
SHIELD agent and along with a couple
other members of the Young Avengers is
able to escape from the bridge in which
they are trapped and travel back to the
location to which they are hiding out at
and what we learned is that this is
actually one of the 20 some-odd secret
bases that Nick Fury has around the
world and that Nick Fury himself is
undercover this is really just kind of a
way from level 2 point to us to say Nick
Fury is still in the picture as far as
Marvel Comics go it's just he's not part
of the Civil War this particular point
in time what we also see is that the
attention of the new warriors the
Patriot Captain America and others is
being drawn to a screen as a press
conference is undergoing involving Tony
Stark and others and this is really kind
of a cool point in the comic because
what we see here is that virtual
the everybody is watching the fantastic
for Susan storm as she sits with Johnny
Storm The Daily Bugle Aunt May and Mary
Jane and and what we see is that
spider-man reveals his identity publicly
now this is a very important point in
Marvel Comics and the reason why is
because over the publication history of
spider-man we've seen his identity
revealed forcefully for the most part
but sometimes willingly of course we saw
him reveal his identity to black cat we
saw where he was supposedly unmasked by
Jay jonah Jameson although he had
tricked Jay jonah Jameson into believing
that it was they were doctorat images
and so on and so forth but this marks
the very first time in which Peter
Parker will stand up in front of cameras
and tell everybody who he is with that
being said I'm going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end I really hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys in the
next video peace you're tuned into
perfecto radio New York City Miami Los
Angeles
make way